yeah welcome to this video and I go e4
it's a five-minute game and let's see
what happens i got one e5 and yeah let's
go for Roy and CM what line we get the
dreaded Berlin yeah i'm not sure that i
really want to play this end game yeah
maybe I go for this rookie one line this
is very safe and maybe I'm still
something to try and kill and so of
course he doesn't need to take
necessarily you can also play d600
Bishop c5 stuff like that but quite
curious that he is investing time now
and some castles are certainly the most
the most popular move maybe it's got
down some other problem yeah well now
defies the classic Berlin Wall end game
I can play rook e1 which is the very
safe move that is played nowadays I
never played this and game okay but not
sure that I want to drive so let's go
rookie one now 96 95 and Bishop e7 as
usual here so on let's drop the bishop
back TM I think deform but i'm not an
expert aha so he's taking
I take with the poem or than I def
five-year but that if I like Georgie
fries probably complete nonsense but ok
let's take here I mean with the rocket
doesn't make much sense to me ok so G
form yeah he's got age six and age for
some possible squares and maybe just
just developed about 95 here d take c 5
9700 sides up all right ok let's just
take you yeah of course now the pawn
structures am completely symmetrical in
the center the question is if there is
something here due to peace activity
I've got the bush and a rock on you one
already so weiter seems to be a bit
ahead in terms of time yeah might be
fine for the idea that I then had it's
not quite clear if he can move the
bishop to some place let's say Bishop c5
I can think about take on d 8 and taking
on c7 are winning a pawn and this also
applies to other bishop moves so I would
them uh-huh ok so so i get i get two
bishops this is something dumb
ok so maybe Quincy fault looks like an
active queen or post maybe I can play
Bishop b5 for Bishop age 6 at some point
uh-huh yeah wants to exchange further
yeah the endgame suddenly as Sam s'okay
for me I mean don't mind the endgame ok
so let's take it it's some complete
symmetry only have two bishops what Jung
of course um is something but did some
not at all easy to to make something
concrete out of this just try to take
some squares with the c3 one issue is
the c7 pawn this is under attack by my
bishop and this means he cannot easily
oppose on the D file for example what
I'd like to do is to get rid of the
neuron f5 to push it back to an even
worse position question is how to do
that g4 is got night age for this
terrible in fact and the bishop d3m
isn't really a threat hmm
yeah this weekend the dark squares also
maybe it may be something like this f3
king f2 and then g4 so night hy can just
cover have three and push the night back
with Bishop g5 or Bishop g3 yeah well
this is my BF 3 as some it's a normal
move anyway to control squares and no i
can actually take c7 but then it's got
93 and this is the idea wants to get rid
of pieces so especially am he wants to
get into some situation with opposite
colored bishops ok so but what if i play
if i play G for now how does he react 9h
fry can play Bishop g5 yeah ok so this
would be a real poem right should I take
this I want to really yeah come on this
is a real porn with real porn I mean
it's not a position with the opposite
colored bishops I hope t7r up g7 ma this
is this is stupid I completely forgot
about this yeah Rock d7 and his
equalizing this ah what a how long again
completely useless in spending the
dispense time now rooty 7 I mean either
you see this move rock t 7 and then you
then you just play it but it doesn't
make any sense to wait now for for
whatever reason taking music group t6 is
just a pretty better end game for a
while yeah go ahead yeah
I cannot i'm taking most terrible i mean
i have simply extremely better end game
if I don't take I can't all shame
forever with the with the bishops this
is some less than nothing I mean it's a
it's a very slight porn weakness on v6
which obviously am never should be
enough to win ok but no just just just
just just a second what about bishop g8
I can play this ok i am but i don't mind
this this is a little bit of something
that is got the pawns on light squares
oh this is just just a very bad move t5
it's not sure that I can benefit but
it's it's it's it's better anyway
download time but I've got pawns nicely
fixed here Bishop c8 is now the idea and
that's it why this willing now
yeah yeah this end game yeah was still a
bit better for white a bit yeah it's a
draw but you can play on of course
taking on d6 was just too quickly played
for me I need to I need to just slowly
improve the position further and then
it's just a nightmare for black need to
defend against White's bishop pair for
ages and now this of course is some it's
just equal what he needs to do here is
some to bring the King to e7 and play
something like f6 in fact here instead
of King III which is a typical blitz
move um kind of quick move you you want
to play I should play g4g 5 go quickly
back to this position yeah I should play
this move this is better to fix the
bronze on on light squares played this
too too too quickly King you three it's
not a big deal but this way I am I
actually am make sure that there are
some points on light squares and the
game played this and now he should
probably play f6 I have g5 yeah this end
game this n Camp isn't really have a
walk in the park I mean you should draw
it but I have a bit a bit of a bit of a
pool alright thanks for watching this
game